first the met gala happened last night  folks that is billy eilish what oh wow  you might be a little surprised right  little nas x there maybe not so much of  a surprise  last year of course was canceled because  of coronavirus this year red carpet a  little bit smaller than normal but  certainly the stars showed out in their  fashion this year's theme in america a  lexicon of fashion and you know i mean  obviously some very interesting outfits  um  and some statement pieces too of course  there's um congresswoman aoc and she had  an address that said tax the rich oh so  so that was a big statement you know and  then some other things but uh always  interesting at the met mm-hmm